what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course the hype from spider-man no way
home is still super super big spider-man
knowing home has just passed spider-man
far from home and has become the highest
grossing spider-man film of all time
congrats to spider-man no way home huge
accomplishment and although people are
still super psyched for spider-man
knowing home and what it means for the
future a lot of people are really
looking forward to doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness now there's a
lot of things that are rumored to be
happening in multiverse of madness and i
have personally heard that some things
are true and based off of what i've
personally heard we are in for a very
very big treat with this movie lots of
rumored cameos and with the multiverse
anything is possible including original
characters from other franchises like
the fox franchise returning and making
cameos in this film and speaking of
characters returning today it looks like
we have some casting news about the new
ghost rider who will be in the marvel
cinematic universe now i would really
really like nick cage to come back and
make at least a cameo as the old ghost
writer there's been no word on that so
far but let's talk about the new casting
developments that we've heard so far and
what it means for the future of the
marvel cinematic universe and of course
if you're new and you want to stay up to
date on all the recent mcu news be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now when it comes to
ghostwriter in the mcu i think the
number one fan casting for who should
play the role of ghost writer johnny
blaze i think was keanu reeves
unfortunately i do not think he's going
to be playing ghost rider as it seems
that ghost rider might have already been
cast and keanu has recently stated in an
interview for the matrix 4 that he has
met with kevin feige to talk about roles
in the mcu but they have not agreed on a
role yet they haven't found a role that
would be perfect for keanu reeves yet so
it's not keanu reeves but good news for
the walking dead fans it could be norman
reedus most people know him as daryl
from the walking dead and there's a
little bit of evidence suggesting that
he could have already been cast as the
mcu's ghostwriter let's take a look at
it now according to charles murphy of
murphy's multiverse.com an actor has
indeed been chosen to play ghostwriter
with this news comes a lot of reports
that norman reedus has been chosen to
play ghostwriter and what's very
interesting about this is that norman
reedus has been liking the tweets tweets
about him himself playing ghostwriter
and tweets just about ghostwriter being
cast in general he's liked several
tweets so far about ghostwriter and to
top it all off on twitter he tweeted a
link to an instagram page that had fan
art of him as ghost rider which is a
pretty big sign so either he's the
greatest troll of all time or there is
actually a decent chance that he has
indeed been cast as johnny blaise aka
ghost writer in the mcu assuming they go
with johnny blaze of course now as far
as when we can expect to see ghost rider
in the mcu all signs right now kind of
point towards doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness we've heard rumors
for over a year now that ghost rider
will be making his mcu debut in
multiverse of madness and at the time we
didn't know if it was going to be an
older ghost writer a variant of ghost
rider or if we would be getting our mcu
ghostwriter in the film and it looks
like it could be our very own
ghostwriter and the timing of this kind
of checks out doctor strange is
supposedly going to introduce many
different new aspects of the mcu one of
those aspects is a darker side to the
mcu remember this movie was originally
supposed to be a horror film scott
derrickson was originally supposed to
direct the film he wanted it to be a
true horror film and what we've heard is
that kevin feige said no it's still
gotta be pg-13 it can't be that much of
a horror film they kind of disagreed
about the vision so they parted ways and
now sam raimi is stepping up who of
course has a horror background and he is
directing multiverse of madness so it's
not going to be all out not going to be
just a true full-on horror film which
i'm excited about i don't really do
horror that well but based off of what
we know it is going to be pretty trippy
and it's going to be dark and introduce
the supernatural side of the mcu such as
dark magic demons and of course we'll
probably explore the dark hold a little
bit more as well which in the comics was
created by an ancient evil elder god
c'thun and like i said a lot of new
things are going to be introduced in
this film and one of those things or i
should say groups is supposedly going to
be some type of a setup for the midnight
suns not sure if they'll all come
together in this film but the setup for
them should happen in multiverse of
madness ghost rider of course is a part
of the midnight suns group and then we
have blade coming to the mcu we've
actually kind of already seen his mcu
debut in the post-credits scene for the
eternals spoiler alert if you haven't
seen it with kid harrington but kit
harrington's dane whitman aka the black
knight is about to pick up the sword and
right before he picks up the sword we
hear a voice ask him if he's sure he
wants to do that it has been confirmed
that this is the voice of mahershala ali
aka the actor who is playing blade in
the mcu so blade has already been
introduced then of course doctor strange
himself is a part of the midnight suns
and then the other big name who is a
part of the midnight suns is the
punisher and i'm not trying to get
anybody's hopes up this is my own
speculation but they did just bring back
charlie cox as matt murdock aka
daredevil and vincent d'onofrio as
wilson fisk aka kingpin in the hawkeye
series so jon returning to play frank
castle aka the punisher isn't off the
table now i want to reiterate i'm not
saying that this is going to happen but
it is definitely a possibility now that
charlie cox and vincent d'onofrio have
returned and with characters like blade
and ghost rider now entering the mcu and
the darker side of the mcu kind of
coming to the front and center stage if
there was a time to bring back jon as
frank castle aka the punisher now's the
time and i know fans would absolutely
lose their minds for that now having
said that i know some fans wanted
gabriel luna from agents of shield to
come back and play ghost rider gabrielle
played an excellent ghost rider for
agents of shield but the way agents of
shield ended and the way kevin feige has
kind of talked about agents of shield in
the past leads me to believe that they
aren't going to bring any characters
from agents of shield into the mcu it's
weird how agents of shield kind of
started off canon and then kind of went
off into its own thing and wasn't canon
by the end there's still some big debate
about it but it doesn't really seem like
any of those characters are going to
return so just because they're bringing
some netflix characters back i would not
expect any agents of shield characters
to come back although i would like to
see coulson in some way shape or form
but unfortunately it looks like gabriel
luna is not going to be reprising his
role as ghost writer in the mcu there
have been reports right now that norman
reedus is going to be ghost rider and he
has been liking these reports and if you
actually look back prior to kingpin's
debut in the mcu in the hawkeye series
vincent d'onofrio actually did the same
thing he would go around twitter liking
tweets about kingpin in the mcu he never
admitted to anything but he would like
things that would state that he is going
to be kingpin in the mcu that was his
sort of subtle way of telling us yes you
are right i'm coming back i can't say it
but i am so perhaps this could be norman
reedus's way of telling us yes you're
right i have been cast as ghost writer i
will be playing ghost rider in the mcu i
can't tell you but i am and if this is
the case if this is true let me know
what you think about this casting in the
comments down below do you like this do
you not like this if you don't like this
who else did you have in mind let me
know down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest mcu news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you